you know it's been a little while since
uh since you've hung out with us have
you been i've been well i've been well
thank you feeling good about things yeah
i do feel good we're the 20s we made it
to the 20s 2020 yeah i think this is
when it really starts to count
do you think so yeah because like in the
last century everybody started talking
about the decades from the 20s on right
nobody was like oh 1909. that was really
fun
that's true no one talked about that no
give me some more in 1913.
yeah no one says that no and i apologize
to everyone that your last 20 years
meant nothing but
kind of didn't mean anything so none of
that counted i'm okay with that oh this
is we start from here and we all made it
so we're going to do we're going to do
great we're going to do great i like
that optimism
you're an optimistic man
i am optimistic i i
definitely am an optimistic person for
sure and i really feel like i feel like
really good about going forward now like
i feel like i feel like obnoxious
a-holes have kind of had a moment
recently like they were really
very i mean they always existed but they
had like a coming out party over the
last couple of years yeah you know what
i mean like you saw a lot more testicles
off the back of pickup trucks yes yeah
yeah
that was never before right uh but you
can see it occasionally but now it yeah
now it's like everybody's got them yeah
and uh i saw them on a saab the other
day
i thought you were gonna say i saw him
on a scooter
[Laughter]
but i feel like now the pendulum will
swing and the good guys will come back
and i feel like yeah i feel like the
good people are going to
have a moment it's a nice thought yeah
and i i think we have to we have to um
it's not just going to happen we have to
participate to you know the good people
have to side with all the people that
the a-holes are against and we have to
support them and then we'll form an army
of uh of good people like um like crying
babies on airplanes right i travel a lot
and uh there's always some obnoxious
businessman next to me uh aggressively
getting angry about a baby because
they're crying on an airplane yeah well
they should be crying they're a baby
on an airplane this is a horrible
situation
[Laughter]
it's horrible for everybody is this a
tube going 500 miles an hour with gassy
human beings you we should all be crying
on the air
the green has it right the baby is
correct they're the only honest ones on
the plate yeah you know
and we would all be crying but we're too
embarrassed so you just mutter prayers
into your bloody mary and hope that the
plane lands
and i'm not even a fan of babies i don't
even i made a couple on i don't like
them
[Applause]
fat little legs
weird little haircuts i'm not a fan but
i'm supporting them and uh look if you
want to complain about uh toddlers uh
flying business class uh i'll listen to
you
i'll listen to you really you have a
problem with that well
yeah yeah i was first on the upgrade
list coming back here from new york and
i'm like oh i'm gonna fly like a rich
guy today i'm number one on the list you
always get it i did not get it everyone
checked in full so i'm going through
business class looking who's in my seat
two toddlers had their own seats in
business class that's tough to take
that's tough to take
i'm trying to be optimistic about the
20s yes and there's toddlers who are
beating me at life
you had to pass them yeah and go back
and they were just sitting that was
crazy i know it's not their money but
they're working it
and they're in business class i'm
sitting in the back eating pretzels like
a praying mantis
[Laughter]
now is this the kind of thing are you a
a guy that complains in that situation
or do you ever do that are you one of
those people that ever says i register a
complaint no no i i slowly swallow the
stress and slowly lose my hair
i don't i don't i don't but you know
look if it takes a lot to get me
aggravated like people like that are
playing their phones without any kind of
air pod or air earbud like you just
think that face timing next to me out
loud i want to kill you i really want to
kill you
that's a huge violation
but i hate conflict so i just kind of
swallow it yeah